THIS IS A SPECIAL HOLIDAY
EDITION OF "CNN NEWSROOM" AND
JIM HAS THE DAY OFF AND WE BEGIN
ON COVID AND BOOSTER SHOTS.
TOP HEALTH OFFICIALS SAY NOT SO
FAST WHEN IT COMES TO COVID-19
BOOSTER SHOTS.
THEY SAY MORE TIME IS NEEDED TO
REVIEW THE DATA.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOW BACKING
OFF ITS PROMISE THAT A THIRD
DOSE OF COVID BOOSTERS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TWO WEEKS FROM
THOUSAND.
RON KLAIN SAID HE DOESN'T KNOW
WHEN AMERICANS COULD GET THEM
BECAUSE THEY'RE WAITING FOR THE
GREEN LIGHT FROM THE FDA.
DR. FAUCI IS CONFIDENT THAT
PFIZER IS SO ON TRACK FOR THAT
SEPTEMBER 20th BOOSTER ROLLOUT.
HE SAID MODERNA'S MAY BE
SLIGHTLY DELAYED BEYOND THAT.
ALL OF THIS COMES AS COVID CASES
ARE SURGING.
ONCE AGAIN IN THE UNITED STATES,
THE SEVEN-DAY AVERAGE OF NEW
CASES FOR 100,000 RESIDENTS IS
300% HIGHER THAN IT WAS ON LABOR
DAY OF LAST YEAR.
THE CDC ALSO SAID CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
FILLING UP WITH COVID CASES AND
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION IS
DANGEROUSLY HIGH.
WE'LL HAVE MUCH MORE ON THIS IN
A MOMENT.
LET'S BEGIN WITH OUR SENIOR
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT ELIZABETH
COHEN.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WHY IS THERE SUCH A LACK OF
CLARITY HERE ON THE BOOSTER?
THE WAY I UNDERSTAND IS THE
WHITE HOUSE SAID WE GOT THEM AND
WE BOUGHT THEM AND NOW WE NEED
THE GREEN LIGHT FROM THE FDA.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD GET THAT
BY THE 20th OF SEPTEMBER?
>> I WANT TO CUT THROUGH ALL OF
THIS AND SAY I DON'T LIKE USING
SPORTS METAPHORS BUT I'M GOING
TO USE ONE NOW.
THIS IS AN UNFORCED ERROR BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
BACK ON AUGUST 18th, THEY SAID
WE'LL BE READY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID WE'LL BE
READY BY AROUND SEPTEMBER 20th
TO DO THIS BOOSTER ROLLOUT.
THEY NEVER SHOULD HAVE NAMED A
SPECIFIC DATE.
THEY SHOULD HAVE SAID BACK THEN,
LOOK IN THE COMING WEEKS AND
MONTHS WE'LL HAVE BOOSTERS
READY.
WE'RE PLANNING, WE'RE PREPARING.
IT WILL HAPPEN.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE AN EXACT DATE.
ONCE YOU GIVE AN EXACT DATE, AS
WE'VE SEEN DURING THIS PANDEMIC,
THINGS HAPPEN.
AND EXACT DATES, YOU DON'T
ALWAYS MEET THE DEADLINES.
SO LET'S LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW WITH THE U.S. BOOSTER
ROLLOUT.
SO, FAUCI HAS SAID THAT PFIZER
LOOKS LIKE THEY'LL BE READY TO
GO THE WEEK OF SEPTEMBER 20th.
SO THAT MEANS IF YOU GOT YOUR
FIRST TWO SHOTS WITH PFIZER, AND
YOU'RE IN THE RIGHT AGE RANGE
AND ALL OF THE OTHER SPECIFICS,
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU COULD GET A
BOOSTER ON SEPTEMBER 20th.
MODERNA, DR. FAUCI SAID, MIGHT
BE BEHIND THAT BY A WEEK OR TWO.
AND THERE COULD BE DATA IN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS ON MIXING AND
MATCHING.
IN OTHER WORDS, JUST BECAUSE YOU
GOT MODERNA THE FIRST TIME,
MAYBE YOU'LL GET A BOOST FRESH
PFIZER OR VICE VERSA.
THAT IS POSSIBLE.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT
FOR ANYONE WHO IS FULLY
VACCINATED AND ENOUGH TIME HAS
PASSED, SAY FIVE MONTHS, SIX
MONTHS, SEVEN MONTHS, EIGHT
MONTHS SOMEWHERE IN THERE, YOU
COULD GET A BOOSTER IN THE
COMING WEEKS OR MONTHS.
IT WILL MOST LIKELY BE OFFERED
AND AVAILABLE TO YOU, NOT THE
WEEK OF SEPTEMBER 20th.
BUT IT WILL HAPPEN.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN TO DR.
FAUCI.
>> PFIZER ONE OF THE COMPANIES
WITH THE MRNA HAS GOTTEN THE
INFORMATION HAS BEEN EXAMINED
AND THINGS LOOK LIKE THEY'RE
READY TO GO.
MODERNA MIGHT BE BEHIND THAT AND
IF THEY ARE WHAT YOU MIGHT SEE
IS RATHER THAN THE SIMULTANEOUS
ROLLING OUT OF THE BOOSTER
PROGRAM OF BOTH DOSE PRODUCTS,
YOU MAY BE SEC -- SEQUENTIAL.
>> AND THEY'VE BEEN KEEPING
TRACK OF HOW PEOPLE ARE DOING IN
ISRAEL.
L
LOOK'S LOOK AT THEIR BOOSTER
ROLLOUT.
THEY BEGAN JULY 30th.
ANYONE IS ELIGIBLE AT FIVE
MONTHS PAST THE SECOND SHOT, IT
DOESN'T MATTER HOW OLD YOU ARE,
IN A STUDY OF PEOPLE AGES 60
PLUS, IT SHOWS THAT THE BOOSTER
REDUCED THE RELATIVE RISK OF
SEVERE ILLNESS MORE THAN 10
TIMES.
POPPY.
>> ELIZABETH, THANK YOU.
OBVIOUSLY FOLLOWING AND WATCHING
VERY CLOSELY WHAT HAPPENS IN
ISRAEL AS MORE PEOPLE GET THE
BOOSTERS.
>>> MORE THAN HALF OF THE
NATION'S SCHOOLS HAVE PART-TIME
NURSES OR NO NURSE AT ALL AND
THE ONGOING SHORTAGE IS TURNING
DIRE AS CHILDREN GO BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM AND AS COVID CASES ARE
ALSO RISING NOW AMONG KIDS.
THE CDC SAID HOSPITALIZATION
RATES FOR CHILDREN HAVE SOARED
THIS SUMMER AS THE DELTA VARIANT
HAS SPREAD.
LET'S GO TO JACQUELINE HOWARD
WITH MORE ON ALL OF THIS.
IT
IT IS JUST MAKING SUCH A TOUGH
SITUATION EACH HARD FER YOU
DON'T HAVE WHAT YOU NEED IN THE
SCHOOL.
>> IF YOU DON'T HAVE A SCHOOL
NURSE, IT IS HARDER TO TEST FOR
COVID-19, TRACK CASES, ISOLATE
CASES.
SO SCHOOL NURSES PLAY A ROLE
SPECIFICALLY IN THE COVID-19
MIST GAGS MEASURES BUT ALSO IN
OTHER EVERY DAY ACTIVITIES LIKE
MAKING SURE A STUDENT WHO MIGHT
HAVE SOME ANXIETY ON THE THE
FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL FEELS
COMFORTABLE AND THOSE WITH FOOD
ALLERGIES ARE OKAY.
SO MANY OTHER THINGS.
SO THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR
YEARS BUT NOW INFECTIOUS DISEASE
EXPERTS AND SCHOOL NURSES THAT
I'VE TALKED TO, THEY ALL SAY
THAT THE SHORTAGE IS BECOMING
DIRE AND BASED ON DATA FROM THE
YEAR 2018, WE COULD ESTIMATE
THAT ABOUT 39% OF SCHOOLS
NATIONWIDE EMPLOY A FULL TIME
NURSE.
ABOUT 35% EMPLOY PART-TIME
NURSES.
BUT THERE IS STILL THAT QUARTER,
ABOUT 25% OF SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE
A SCHOOL NURSE AT ALL.
AND THERE ARE SOME DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKERS WHO ARIE -- ARE HOPIN
TO ADDRESS THIS.
DINA TITUS AND MONTANA SENATOR
JON TESTER HAVE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION CALLED THE NURSE
ACT.
AND CONGRESSWOMAN TITUS'S OFFICE
SAID THE NURSE ACT WOULD PROVIDE
FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION GRANTS
TO HIRE SCHOOL NURSES, THE FIRST
INVESTMENT OF ITS KIND.
NOW CONGRESSWOMAN IS ALSO
PUSHING FOR THIS BILL TO BE IN
THE UPCOMING BUDGET
RECONCILIATION PACKAGE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS THERE,
POPPY.
BUT OF COURSE THIS IS AN ONGOING
ISSUE.
AND SCHOOL NURSES I'VE TALKED TO
REALLY HOPE THAT THE PANDEMIC
CAN SHED LIGHT ON THIS AND LEAD
TO CHANGE.
>> YEAH.
OF COURSE.
JACQUELINE, THANK YOU FOR THE
REPORTING VERY MUCH.
>>> LET ME BRING IN TO TALK
ABOUT ALL OF THESE HEADLINES,
DR. CHRIS BURNELL, FELLOW AT THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF PREVENTATIVE
MEDICINE AND I SHOULD NOTE YOU
PARTICIPATED IN THE MODERNA
VACCINE TRIAL AFTER YOU LOST
YOUR OWN FATHER TO COVID-19.
WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE YOU BACK.
TH
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
>> GOOD MORNING, POPPY.
>> WHERE IS YOUR HEAD NOW THIS
MORNING AMID ALL OF THE
HEADLINES AND THE REAL UNKNOWN
ABOUT WHEN BOOSTERS MIGHT BE
COMING, NAMELY MODERNA WHICH YOU
WERE PART THE INITIAL TRIAL.
>> DEFINITELY.
WHERE I WANT THE PUBLIC AND THE
COMMUNITY TO FOCUS IS THAT WE
NEED TO REV UP OUR GAME AND I
USE THAT SPORTS ANALOGY JUST TO
CONTINUE WITH THE PREVIOUS
CONVERSATION.
WE NEED TO REV UP OUR GAME
AROUND GETTING UNVACCINATED
PERSONS VACCINATED.
YES, BOOSTERS ARE IMPORTANT.
YES, THE WHITE HOUSE HAD A
MISSTEP IN ITS COMMUNICATION BY
GIVING A SPECIFIC DATE BUT I
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO LOSE SIGHT,
THE ONE WAY TO END THIS
PANDEMIC, BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
WHIPLASH.
WE STARTED TO SEE PROGRESS ABOUT
MAY AND JUNE, AND THEN DAILY
CASES ARE EXPLODING.
HOSPITALS ARE AT THEIR END.
WE NEED TO GET UNVACCINATED
FOLKS VACCINATED, WHILE THEN
THINKING ABOUT A RATIONAL
STRATEGY AROUND BOOSTERS,
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE AND MOST AT RISK.
>> ON TOP OF ALL OF THIS, WE
HAVE THE HAVOC THAT HURRICANE
IDA WREAKED ON THE GULF COAST,
ON NEW JERSEY, WHERE YOUR
HOSPITAL IS, IN NEW YORK.
WHAT IS THE IMPACT BEEN FOR YOU
ARE GUYS?
>> WELL IDA DID WHAT
UNFORTUNATELY A HURRICANE DOES.
WHENEVER THERE IS ANY TYPE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DISASTER AND
HURRICANE IS PUBLIC HEALTH
DISASTER YOU HAVE FLASH FLOODS
AND TORNADOS THAT TOUCHED DOWN
IN NEW JERSEY AND THAT PUT
COMMUNITIES FURTHER ON EDGE.
I HAVE PEOPLE IN MY FAMILY WHO
WERE IMPACTED BY IDA.
AND SO WHENEVER YOU HAVE
VULNERABLE OR MARGINALIZED
GROUPS, GROUPS ALREADY AT RISK,
GROUPS LG BELEAGUERED BY THE
PANDEMIC, A PUBLIC HEALTH
DISASTER JUST WORSENS IT.
>> WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE RIGHT NOW AND
THE -- AND I DON'T WANT TO
DISCOUNT THAT WE'RE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN VACCINATIONS.
THAT IS A GOOD THING.
RIGHT.
ESPECIALLY IN STATES THAT WE
WEREN'T SEE ITTING BEFORE AND
HAS THE HIGH COVID RATES AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS.
BUT NOW THE FOCUS OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE MEDIA
ATTENTION IS ON BOOSTERS.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS ARE YOU
AT ALL CONCERNED THAT THAT IS
SPEAKING TO THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ALREADY ACKNOWLEDGED THE
IMPORTANCE OF VACCINATION RATHER
THAN TACKLING THOSE WHO ARE
STILL HIS ESITANT TO GET AN INIL
VACCINE.
>> I'M VERY CONCERNED IF I COULD
BE FORTHCOMING.
I DON'T WANT US TO LOSE SIGHT OF
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE END GAME
IS.
IN THIS PANDEMIC, THERE WILL BE
SEVERAL FINISH LINES AND WE
DON'T WAN TO EVER DECLARE
PREMATURE VICTORY OR GET OUR
EYES OFF OF WHAT IS MOST
ESSENTIAL.
AND WHAT IS MOST ESSENTIAL IS
ENSURING THAT THOSE WHO ARE
UNVACCINATED GET VACCINATED.
LOOK, IF YOU'RE UNVACCINATED,
YOUR RISK OF HOSPITALIZATIONS,
YOUR RISK OF DEATH IS NOT EVEN
COMPARABLE TO IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED.
THIS IS ABOUT GETTING THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE WITH THE MOST ROBUST
PROTECTION AND I'M IN FAVOR OF
THAT BUT I WANT TO RIGHT SIZE
THE URGENCY AND THE MESSAGE.
>> THANK Y